alright let's talk a little bit about
Rand Paul and Marco Rubio Rand Paul
destroyed Marco Rubio in last night's
Republican debate Marco Rubio first here
talking about military and safety take a
listen
significant issues on policy but I
respect Rand he believes everything he
stands for I do respect grandma but I
want to be frank about what I stand for
I believe the world is a safer and a
better place when America is the
strongest power in the world and I
believe only with a strong America will
we defeat this radical group this
apocalyptic group called Isis that's why
when I'm president we are going to
rebuild our intelligence capabilities
and they're gonna tell us where the
terrorists are and a rebuilt US military
is going to destroy these terrorists and
if we capture any of these Isis killers
alive they are going to Guantanamo Bay
Cuba and we're gonna find out everything
they know because when I'm president
unlike Barack Obama we will keep this
country safe
all right so Marco Rubio of Akintola
neoconservative warmongering Kirk clown
and immediately Rand Paul takes him down
watch just very quickly I'd like to
respond the bulk collection of your
phone data the invasion of your privacy
did not stop one terrorist attack I
don't think you have to give up your
Liberty for a false sense of security
when we look at this bulk collection the
court has looked at this even the court
declared it to be illegal if we want to
collect the records of terrorists let's
do it the old-fashioned way let's use
the Fourth Amendment let's put a name on
a warrant let's ask a judge for it let's
respect the history of our country John
Adams said that we fought the war for
independence because we wanted to fight
against generalized warrants let's don't
forget that Governor Kasich Rand Paul
totally taking down Marco Rubio and here
he is doing it again on the topic of
Syria with military activity so it was
not against Isis well guess it was
against Assad I think the United States
military is already operating under
rules of engagement that are too strict
and do not allow us to pursue victory
when I'm president that will change
herself
Senator Paul thank you the issue in
Syria is a very important one and it's
one we need to get right the question is
should we be bombing both sides of the
war some want to topple Assad in fact
they want to bomb Isis and Assad
simultaneously I think that's a really
really bad idea in fact I've said for
several years that arming the Allies of
Isis will make this situation worse that
what we really need to do is defeat Isis
but if you defeat Assad what you will
wind up with is a larger and more
powerful Isis that occupies that space
you might you may well see in Isis it
takes over all of Syria there it is Rand
Paul destroying Marco Rubio and last
night's debate the online news world is
getting pretty cluttered with lots of
nonsense there's the so-called news
sites that just rewrite news articles
and then there's the web sites we all
know that we just can't trust lately
I've been reading smash pipe which is an
online magazine that does original
alternative news and satirical news with
an unapologetic perspective and a roving
moral Center smash pipe is less
interested in trending topics than in
what's actually going on and smash pipe
has no ads whatsoever other than reader
generated classified ads and they never
will smash pipe is what happens when you
on a bad day stub your toe on the
miseries and mysteries of life check it
out at smash pipe calm